que dice la primera ley de newton la
primera ley de newton dice que los
objetos no van a cambiar su velocidad a
menos que exista una fuerza no
equilibrada así que si no hay una fuerza
sobre un objeto o las fuerzas están
equilibradas
entonces el objeto se seguirá moviendo
con una velocidad constante o si se
encuentra en reposo se mantendrá en
reposo en otras palabras no tiene que
haber una fuerza neta para que algo
tenga movimiento solo tiene que haber
una fuerza neta para que algo se acelere
es importante hacer notar que la primera
ley de newton no solo aplica para
objetos solos también aplica a sistemas
de objetos en otras palabras si
consideramos un sistema de objetos y
vemos el centro de masa de ese sistema
el centro de masa del sistema
permanecerá en reposo o permanecerá en
movimiento constante siempre y cuando no
haya una fuerza externa no equilibrada
en el sistema
estos objetos puede que ejerzan fuerzas
entre ellos pero el centro de masa
permanecerá en reposo o con una
velocidad constante a menos que llegue
una fuerza no equilibrada externa al
sistema cual sería un ejemplo de un
problema de la primera ley de newton
digamos que un elevador pesado puede ser
levantado por un cable que ejerce una
fuerza fs el elevador se mueve hacia
arriba con una velocidad constante de 5
metros por segundo queremos saber cómo
se compara la fuerza del cable con la
fuerza de gravedad y un error muy común
es pensar que ya que el objeto se está
moviendo hacia arriba la fuerza que va
hacia arriba debe ser más grande pero no
es así porque esto se está moviendo
hacia arriba con una velocidad constante
y por eso las fuerzas tienen que estar
equilibradas ya que la primera ley de
newton dice que si la fuerza neta es
cero
el objeto mantendrá una velocidad
constante
y para que la fuerza neta sea cero estas
fuerzas se tienen que cancelar aun
cuando esto no nos parezca intuitivo la
fuerza del cable tiene que ser igual a
la fuerza de gravedad para que el
elevador se pueda mover con una
velocidad constante
qué significa la segunda ley de newton
la segunda ley de newton dice que la
aceleración de un objeto es proporcional
a la fuerza neta e inversamente
proporcional a la masa que si lo vemos
en forma de ecuación nos dice que la
aceleración de un objeto va a ser igual
a la fuerza neta sobre ese objeto
dividida entre la masa del objeto y esta
fórmula funciona para cada dirección
individual en otras palabras la
aceleración en la dirección x es igual a
la fuerza neta en x dividida entre la
masa y la aceleración en la dirección y
es igual a la fuerza neta en la
dirección y dividida entre la masa como
se vería un problema de la segunda ley
de newton digamos que una roca espacial
de 5 kilogramos sólo tiene actuando
sobre sí a las fuerzas mostradas en el
diagrama y queremos determinar la
aceleración en la dirección horizontal
ya que horizontal es la dirección x
solo usaremos las fuerzas en la
dirección x para así poder determinar la
aceleración en esta dirección
x lo que quiere decir que no vamos a
tomar en cuenta la fuerza de 15 newtons
y de 5 newtons estas fuerzas no
contribuyen a la aceleración en la
dirección x las únicas fuerzas que
contribuyen a la aceleración es el
componente horizontal de esta fuerza de
10 newtons que es 10 coseno de 30 grados
y la fuerza de 40 mil tons por lo que la
aceleración en la dirección x va a ser
igual a la fuerza neta en la dirección x
que será 10 por coseno de 30 grados y es
una contribución positiva ya que va
hacia la derecha menos 40 que es una
contribución negativa ya que va hacia la
izquierda y finalmente dividimos esto en
35 kilogramos lo que nos da la
aceleración correcta en la dirección x
qué significa la tercera ley de newton
la tercera ley de newton dice que si el
objeto a ejerce una fuerza sobre el
objeto b entonces el objeto b debe
ejercer una fuerza equivalente y opuesta
sobre el objeto a y esto se cumple aún
si los objetos tienen tamaños o
aceleraciones diferentes
en otras palabras digamos que la tierra
está atrayendo a un asteroide aún cuando
la tierra es mucho más grande que el
asteroide el asteroide va a ejercer una
fuerza equivalente y opuesta sobre la
tierra y esto se cumple sin importar que
el asteroide se esté moviendo con una
velocidad constante o si está acelerando
como se vería un problema que involucre
a la tercera ley de newton
digamos que una esfera de metal se
encuentra arriba de una caja de cartón
cuál de los siguientes son pares de
fuerzas de la tercera ley de newton la
primera opción dice que hay una fuerza
hacia arriba ejercida por la caja sobre
la esfera así que para encontrar la
fuerza acompañante lo único que tenemos
que hacer es cambiar el orden de los
objetos lo que significa que la pareja
de esta fuerza va a ser una fuerza
ejercida por la esfera sobre la caja que
no es lo que dice aquí así que esta
opción no es la opción ve menciona una
fuerza hacia arriba ejercida por la mesa
sobre la caja y sabemos que si
intercambiamos las etiquetas tendremos
la fuerza acompañante que sería una
fuerza ejercida por la caja sobre la
mesa que no es esto no es la opción ve
la opción se menciona una fuerza
ejercida por la caja sobre la esfera
si intercambiamos las etiquetas va a ser
una fuerza sobre la caja ejercida por la
esfera que no es lo que dice aquí y la
opción de se refiere a una fuerza
ejercida por la mesa sobre la caja que
si intercambiamos las etiquetas va a ser
una fuerza acompañante ejercida por la
caja sobre la mesa que justo es lo que
dice aquí así que efectivamente nuestra
respuesta es el inciso d es un par de
fuerzas de la tercera ley de newton lo
que significa que ambas siempre deben
ser iguales y opuestas otros pares
pueden ser opuestos e iguales pero sin
importar que ocurran estas dos fuerzas
siempre tienen que ser iguales y
opuestas como podemos encontrar la
fuerza de gravedad que actúa sobre un
objeto cerca de la tierra la fuerza de
gravedad en todos los objetos cercanos a
la tierra va a apuntar hacia abajo hacia
el centro de la tierra y va a ser igual
a la masa por la aceleración de la
gravedad otra palabra para referirse a
la
fuerza de gravedad es el peso de un
objeto pero tengan cuidado el peso no es
la masa el peso es la fuerza de gravedad
lo que significa que el peso es igual a
m porque no la masa solita la fuerza de
gravedad es un vector y tiene unidades
de newtons como luce un problema que
involucra a la fuerza de gravedad
digamos que conocemos la masa y el peso
de un menor que son de 5 kilogramos y 49
newtons respectivamente
cuando los medimos en la tierra cuáles
serán los valores de la masa y el peso
del melón si lo llevamos a la luna el
valor de la masa no va a cambiar ya que
es la medida de la cantidad de sustancia
en ese objeto pero el peso del melón en
la luna si va a cambiar y va a ser menor
ya que el tirón gravitatorio de la luna
es más débil así que la única opción
consistente con ambas condiciones es el
inciso a ya que la masa permanece igual
el peso es menor
qué es la fuerza normal la fuerza normal
es la fuerza exterior perpendicular a la
fuerza ejercida sobre una superficie no
hay una fórmula específica para calcular
la fuerza normal simplemente tenemos que
usar la segunda ley de newton para esto
hacemos que la fuerza normal sea una de
las incógnitas de las fuerzas actuando
en esa dirección y la despejamos si
tenemos una masa sobre una superficie
horizontal y no tenemos alguna otra
fuerza involucrada la fuerza normal solo
tiene que equilibrar a la fuerza de
gravedad lo que significa que la fuerza
normal simplemente será igual a m por g
pero si hay otras fuerzas actuando aquí
o si existe aceleración en la misma
dirección que la fuerza normal entonces
la fuerza normal no va a ser igual a m
por g y tendremos que usar la segunda
ley de newton en esa dirección para
encontrarla la palabra normal en la
fuerza normal se refiere al hecho de que
esta fuerza siempre va a ser pp
a la superficie que está ejerciendo esta
fuerza y es bueno recordar que para una
masa sobre una pendiente esa fuerza
normal no va a ser igual a m por g va a
ser igual a m porque x coseno de t está
la fuerza normal es un vector ya que es
una fuerza y sus unidades son de newtons
como se vería un problema que involucre
a la fuerza normal digamos que una
persona empuja una caja en reposo de
masa m contra el techo con una fuerza
afp y lo hace con un ángulo theta
queremos saber cuál es la magnitud de la
fuerza normal ejercida por el techo
sobre la caja dibujamos un diagrama de
fuerzas tenemos la fuerza
afp de la persona la fuerza m por g de
la gravedad si la caja está en reposo
debe existir una fuerza que evite que la
caja se deslice sobre el techo que
probablemente será una fuerza de
fricción estática y también tendremos
una fuerza normal pero esta fuerza
normal no va a estar apuntando hacia
arriba
fuerza normal del techo no va a apuntar
hacia arriba la fuerza normal del techo
solo puede apuntar hacia afuera de la
casa que es hacia abajo así que nuestra
fuerza normal estará en la dirección
vertical por lo que sólo vamos a
analizar las fuerzas que están en la
dirección vertical y sabemos que estas
fuerzas deben estar balanceadas
verticalmente ya que esta caja no tiene
ningún movimiento vertical en otras
palabras la fuerza normal más la fuerza
de gravedad deben ser iguales al
componente vertical de esta fuerza
afp que ya que se encuentra del lado
opuesto del ángulo podemos escribirla
como fdp por el seno de theta despejamos
la fuerza normal que es igual a afp por
el seno de teta menos m por g vean que
no tuvimos que usar la fuerza de
fricción ni el componente horizontal de
la fuerza en gp ya que la fuerza normal
se encuentra en la dirección vertical
qué significa la fuerza de tensión la
fuerza de tensión es la fuerza ejercida
por una cuerda cadena cable o cualquier
objeto similar a una cuerda la atención
solo puede jalar un objeto en otras
palabras una cuerda no puede empujar un
objeto de manera similar a la forma
normal no hay una fórmula específica
para la atención para encontrar la
atención tenemos que incluirla como una
incógnita en la segunda ley de newton y
después despejar la y ya que la fuerza
de tensión siempre jala el objeto cuando
dibujen su diagrama de fuerzas
asegúrense de dibujar las fuerzas de
atención hacia afuera del objeto en
donde la cuerda está ejerciendo esta
fuerza esto es un vector ya que es una
fuerza y sus unidades son de newtons
como luce un problema que involucra a la
tensión
digamos que dos cuerdas sostienen una
caja en reposo y queremos saber cómo se
comparan las magnitudes de las tensiones
en las dos cuerdas si dibujamos nuestro
diagrama de fuerzas
tendremos una fuerza hacia abajo que es
la fuerza de gravedad
tendremos una fuerza de tensión a la
izquierda y otra fuerza de atención
diagonal hacia la derecha y ya que la
caja está en reposo las fuerzas tienen
que estar equilibradas en todas las
direcciones lo que significa que el
componente vertical de t2 tiene que ser
igual a la magnitud de la fuerza de
gravedad y el componente horizontal de
t2 tiene que ser igual a la magnitud de
la fuerza de uno pero si un componente
de t2 es igual a toda la magnitud de tf1
entonces la magnitud de t 2 completa va
a ser mayor que de 1 en otras palabras
si una parte de t 2 es igual a t
entonces este 2 completo va a ser más
grande que t 1 que significa la fuerza
de fricción cinética la fuerza de
fricción cinética es la fuerza que trata
de evitar que las superficies se
deslicen la fuerza de fricción cinética
es proporcional a la fuerza normal entre
ambas superficies y también es
proporcional al coeficiente de fricción
cinética entre estas dos superficies
noten que la fuerza de fricción cinética
no depende de la velocidad del objeto en
otras palabras si la fuerza normal y el
coeficiente de fricción cinética son
iguales entonces no importa qué tan
rápido o lento vaya el objeto no importa
qué tan fuerte o suave hallemos el
objeto la fuerza de fricción cinética va
a mantener el mismo valor y ya que la
fricción cinética es una fuerza es un
vector y sus unidades son de newtons
como se vería un problema que involucre
la fuerza de fricción cinética
que tenemos un auto que viaja con cierta
velocidad de crucero frena de golpe y
patina hasta detenerse queremos saber
cuáles dos cambios aumentarían la
distancia requerida para que el auto
patinó hasta detenerse para tener una
intuición de lo que debe pasar para que
este auto recorra una mayor distancia
antes de detenerse vamos a usar una
fórmula cinemática ya que el auto patina
hasta detenerse la velocidad final será
de cero si despejamos la distancia ésta
va a ser igual a menos de cero al
cuadrado entre dos veces la aceleración
así que para que el auto patinó una
mayor distancia podemos aumentar la
velocidad inicial del auto o reducir la
desaceleración para ver que disminuye la
magnitud de la aceleración usaremos la
segunda ley de newton la fuerza que
disminuye al auto que está patinando es
la fuerza de fricción cinética y ya que
no tenemos ninguna fuerza vertical
externa
fuerza normal es m por g
aquí las masas se cancelan por lo que la
aceleración no va a depender de la masa
del auto si reducimos el coeficiente de
fricción cinética va a reducir la
magnitud de la desaceleración y el
reducir la desaceleración va a aumentar
la distancia que recorre el auto antes
de detenerse la fuerza de fricción
estática evita que las superficies se
deslicen y esta fuerza de fricción
estática será igual a la fuerza que
trata de hacer que el objeto se deslice
y esto se va a cumplir hasta que esta
fuerza que trata de hacer que se deslice
el objeto sea igual a la máxima fuerza
de fricción estática que es proporcional
a la fuerza normal y también es
proporcional al coeficiente de fricción
estática si el valor máximo de esta
fuerza de fricción estática es de 100
newtons y tratamos de hacer que el
objeto se deslice usando solamente 80
newtons la fuerza de fricción estática
se nos va a oponer con una fuerza de 80
newtons evitando así que el objeto se
deslice
si ejercemos 90 minutos la fuerza de
fricción estática va a aumentar hasta
llegar a 90 minutos nuevamente a
evitando que el objeto se deslice pero
si ejercemos una fuerza de 110 newtons
ya que esto es mayor que el máximo
posible de la fuerza de fricción
estática el objeto se va a deslizar y
sólo nos quedará una fuerza de fricción
cinética una vez que el objeto se está
deslizando como luce un problema que
involucra a la fuerza de fricción
estática digamos que empujas un
refrigerador de 180 kilogramos de masa y
el coeficiente de fricción estática
entre el refrigerador y el suelo es de
punto 8 si ejercemos 50 newtons de
fuerza horizontal sobre el refrigerador
cuál es la magnitud de la fricción
estática ejercida por el suelo sobre el
refrigerador primero tenemos que
encontrar cuál es el máximo de la fuerza
de fricción estática y lo hacemos usando
muelle por fm y ya que no tenemos
ninguna fuerza vertical externa
nuestra fuerza normal va a ser igual a m
porque ponemos los valores y esto nos va
a dar que la fuerza de fricción estática
máxima posible es de 1.411 newtons pero
este no va a ser el valor de la fuerza
de fricción estática este simplemente es
el valor máximo de esta fuerza de
fricción estática así que si ejercemos
una fuerza de 50 newtons a la derecha ya
que esto no excede el máximo de la
fuerza de fricción estática la fuerza de
fricción solamente se va a oponer con
una fuerza de 50 newtons una fuerza
igual pero a la izquierda y va a seguir
igualando cualquiera que sea la fuerza
que nosotros ejerzamos sobre el
refrigerador hasta que superemos el
máximo posible de esta fuerza de
fricción estática
como trabajamos con las pendientes las
pendientes simplemente son superficies
con cierta inclinación en las que los
objetos pueden deslizarse hacia arriba o
hacia abajo y ya que el objeto no puede
moverse adentro de esta superficie o
hacia afuera de esta superficie el
movimiento sólo puede ser paralelo a
esta superficie no tendremos ninguna
aceleración perpendicular a la
superficie así que en lugar de
descomponer nuestras fuerzas en x y las
descomponemos en fuerzas perpendiculares
y paralelas a la superficie el
componente de la gravedad que es
paralelo a la superficie va a ser igual
a m por g por el seno de teta donde teta
es el ángulo entre el suelo horizontal y
la superficie inclinada y el componente
de la gravedad que es perpendicular a la
superficie va a ser igual a m por g por
el coseno detecta donde nuevamente theta
es el ángulo que se forma entre el suelo
y esta superficie y ya que no tenemos
ninguna aceleración perpendicular a la
superficie
fuerza neta en la dirección
perpendicular tiene que ser igual a 0 lo
que significa que el componente
perpendicular de la gravedad tiene que
ser compensado por la fuerza normal y es
por eso que el valor de la fuerza normal
es el mismo que el del componente
perpendicular de la gravedad y ya que
estos componentes perpendiculares se
cancelan la fuerza neta total sobre un
objeto que se encuentra en una pendiente
será igual al componente de la fuerza
neta que es paralela a la superficie y
si no tiene fricción está simplemente va
a ser igual a m por g por el seno de
teta y si existiera fricción la fuerza
neta sería igual a m por g por el seno
de teta menos la fuerza de fricción pero
tengan cuidado cuando encuentren la
fuerza de fricción en una pendiente ya
que la fuerza normal no va a ser m
porque la fuerza normal será m porque x
coseno de teta como no sea un problema
que involucra a las pendientes pues
digamos que tenemos una caja que
comienza con una gran velocidad
de baja de una rampa sin fricción y se
va deslizando hacia arriba de la rampa
pasando por estos puntos que marcamos
como w x y y ceta
queremos clasificar las magnitudes de la
fuerza neta sobre la caja para los
puntos indicados cuando la caja se
encuentra volando en el aire sabemos que
la fuerza neta simplemente será la
fuerza de gravedad hacia abajo que es m
por g así que las fuerzas
iceta son iguales y en una pendiente la
fuerza neta es el componente de la
fuerza que es paralela a la superficie
con la pendiente que será m por g por el
seno de theta noten que la fuerza neta
en esta superficie con pendiente apunta
hacia abajo de la pendiente aún cuando
la masa se mueve hacia arriba de la
pendiente lo que significa que la masa
va disminuyendo su velocidad pero ya que
el eje es más grande que m por g por el
seno de teta z y van a ser mayores que
la fuerza en xy w
qué significa tratar un sistema como un
solo objeto es un truco que podemos usar
cuando dos o más objetos se mueven con
la misma rapidez o aceleración lo que
nos evitará usar múltiples ecuaciones
para encontrar la aceleración y solo
usar una ecuación para obtener la
aceleración cuando tratamos a un sistema
de objetos como un solo objeto podemos
ignorar las fuerzas internas ya que las
fuerzas internas siempre se van a
cancelar lo que significa que puede
encontrar la aceleración de un sistema
observando solamente las fuerzas
externas a este sistema y dividiendo
todo entre la masa total del sistema
como sería un ejemplo que involucre el
tratar un sistema de objetos como un
solo objeto digamos que tenemos una masa
m1 que es jalada a través de una mesa
horizontal rugosa por una cuerda
conectada con la masa m2 si el
coeficiente de fricción cinética entre
la masa m 1 y la mesa es
cuál será la expresión para la magnitud
de la aceleración de las masas aquí en
lugar de analizar las fuerzas en cada
una de las masas de forma individual en
donde tendríamos que usar múltiples
ecuaciones y múltiples variables vamos a
usar una sola ecuación de la segunda ley
de newton y trataremos a este sistema
como si fuera un solo objeto lo que
básicamente significa que nos vamos a
preguntar cuáles son las fuerzas
externas que hacen que el sistema se
mueva o se detenga la fuerza externa que
hace que se mueva el sistema es la
fuerza de gravedad que apunta hacia
abajo que actúa en m2 es una fuerza
externa porque está siendo ejercida por
la tierra que no forma parte de nuestro
sistema y cómo hace que nuestro sistema
se mueva va a ser una fuerza positiva y
las fuerzas que traten de detener a
nuestro sistema las vamos a considerar
como negativas como esta fuerza de
fricción cinética en m1 que también es
una fuerza externa ya que la mesa no
forma parte de nuestro sistema pero
vamos a incluir las fuerzas de tensión
ya que estas son las fuerzas internas y
se van a cancelar y como estamos
tratando a este objeto como si fuera una
sola masa vamos a dividir esto entre la
masa total y si queremos escribir la
fuerza de fricción cinética en términos
de su coeficiente vamos a poner nunca
por la fuerza normal y la fuerza normal
en m uno va a ser igual a m uno por g y
ahora con una sola ecuación tenemos la
expresión de la aceleración de nuestro
sistema sin tener que resolver varias
ecuaciones con varias incógnitas